whatever man have you stay you play by
my rules
come on man you know me I love a good
fight man an iron fist
it's got a ring to it that's going on a
t-shirt for real fire it up a hit my
hands I'm ready this time
[Music]
you can accept your bulletproof right
and you can accept that my hand it it
glows but you can't accept the dragon
he'll know one day I'm gonna take you to
come on I'm gonna introduce you to
shallow tongue long hollow will you give
you the in German dude have some respect
because my history hey everybody it's
Charlie this is gonna be my new Luke
Cage Power Man Iron Fist Heroes for Hire
video obviously spoiler warning if you
haven't seen the series yet I'm trying
to wait just a little while before doing
some of these videos to give people a
chance to watch the series but as you
can see they went a long way towards
fixing the Iron Fist character and
giving you a version of what we've
wanted from these Netflix series since
they announced them so let's break this
down if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the Marvel
videos there's infinity war blu-ray
giveaway stuff that I'll explain at the
end of the video too but quick recap
Danny Rand and Colleen wing enter the
series via misty knights bionic arm and
Danny's businesses because they bloat
one of them up in an earlier episode
over the course of the series Luke
starts to drive a wedge between him and
Claire temple night nurse he turns into
more of a Godfather Michael Corleone's
situation so in episode 10 Claire temple
asks Danny to go check in on Luke to
make sure that he's okay so while he's
doing that Danny gets caught up in
Luke's fight you know me I love a good
fight along the way they make all kinds
of references to Power Man and Iron Fist
like I included in that clip there's
even more than that then later while
they're talking Danny also makes fun of
himself from Iron Fist Season one you
know sometimes you gotta face things
head-on on your own
oh boy you're starting to sound like I
did it's not good
stubborn don't you just love that so you
have to imagine that this is the Luke
Cage show runner doing his version of
iron fist it's not somebody else writing
the character so credit where credit is
due he went a long way towards redeeming
that character just the kind of energy
the kind of series that we're looking
for if they could do a season with 10 to
12 episodes like this I feel like they
would be on their a-game like Luke Cage
is a serious is very well crafted it
just doesn't have quite as much team-up
comic-book action as I would like to see
from a series that has Marvel in the
title but a couple big things here
obviously Danny goes off to his own
business after this and Luke Cage
finishes the season out but the teaser
that he leaves with I'm gonna take you
to Kunlun Sunday and introduce you to
that dragon
come out of the darkness so I can see
you they make all kinds of jokes about
the dragon
you fought Bruce Lee no no it was a real
dragon see I became the fist when I
defeated Shou Lao it's a dragon
wait Mao you fought Bruce Lee no no no
no not Bruce Lee a real then later when
they're in Turks head shop Danny picks
up the pipe shaped like a dragon I like
this one I like this one
his mole they make all kinds of jokes
about Danny being a really big smoker
apparently they grow really awesome weed
and Kunlun mines NameNode apothecary
back and come live any sickness any pain
old Ming would have a leaf or a remedy
for it
Souleymane had that k-town chronic we
know with a chronic so in addition to
just being a really awesome team up and
having some funny moments they also lay
in some deeper meaning to the scenes
there are references to the origin of
the Iron Fist character how the
character himself was inspired by the
kung-fu craze from Bruce Lee and Chuck
Norris back during the 70s so another
big part of this was also the wu-tang
track that was playing it was actually
wu-tang's 7th chamber part 2 when they
were fighting when they did the
pattycake but the Luke aides showrunner
this responsible for all this he said
it's not so much about them just
continuing that defender scene where
they had the wu-tang track when they
first met up is about them picking the
right whoo tang track so punch east okay
now
[Music]
complicated
the example he gave is that he said I
told all my fight choreographers I want
Shaw Brothers type of coverage not hyper
cut Paul Greengrass during Bourne
Identity I want you to actually see
people fighting in frame like Wachowski
brothers doing that during the Matrix
movies or Quentin Tarantino doing that
during the Kill Bill films those fight
scenes that's where the fun is that's
where the genre is it's important to
reflect that so this far I think the
Luke Cage showrunner has actually had
the best take on Iron Fist now Netflix
is bringing an Iron Fist season to panel
to comic-con I don't know if they're
gonna show off a trailer they finished
shooting it a while ago
so maybe they'll have some footage but
there's a big question about whether or
not they're gonna drop that season
before they drop daredevil season 3
because everybody still thinks that matt
is dead right now but they shot
daredevil season 3 before they shot Iron
Fist season 2 so it'll be a little weird
if they sat on that so we'll find out
more about that in a couple of weeks but
let me know in the comments do you
actually want them to just stop doing
Luke Cage and Iron Fist separate TV
shows and just have them team up and do
a Heroes for Hire Power Man Iron Fist
show I get it
you don't have to carry this burden by
yourself you're downtown I'm up town
same island same city we're just
defending different neighborhoods
together Matt Murdock [ __ ] I definitely
think that Luke Cage is gonna get more
seasons will see how Iron Fist season 2
works out it just depends on what it
looks like congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner geeky boy productions
please private message me so I can get
your contact details there's an infinity
war blu-ray giveaway that's going on all
you have to do to enter those is be a
subscriber leave a comment on the video
I'll name a new winner when I post new
Marvel click here to learn all about
phase 4 and the Doctor Strange sequel
and click here for that brand new
Captain Marvel promo thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight